i'm emily blunt hey guys i'm dwayne
johnson and this is the wired auto
complete
interview you're ready
wait so this people really google this
what dwayne johnson eats in a day
what do you eat in a day buffalo buffalo
yeah but a scrambly egg
some egg in it some oatmeal and of just
a hot hot dog swallowed hole
and a hot dog swallowed hole he just
loves sausages
wow again is that right yeah what else
what else what
what's your next meal a little bit of
chicken oh we're still on rice
it's in a date all right goodbye hit
that board okay they were like they
heard buffalo they thought
what is dwayne johnson's tattoo
a lot of things this is take your shirt
okay they can't see it they can't see it
i have a really big polynesian tattoo
that tells the story of my life
and then on this side emily blunt's face
mixed with what was dwayne johnson's
first job my legit first job i was 13
years old and i worked in a pizza shop
and i washed dishes
middle school every day from three
o'clock till 11 30.
are you still a good dishwasher i only
as a matter of fact
some nerdy is uh and weird i need
therapy
is you know i don't use a dishwasher
ever ever no
what about for a big load i hand wash
everything everything what was dwayne
johnson's
football injury i've had many i've had a
complete shoulder separation here that
required
complete reconstruction of my shoulder
had five knee surgeries
from football and um that's why you have
a fake leg and a torn achilles
no i don't have a fake leg no it doesn't
all my legs are real
what can dwayne johnson bench i do want
to know this
what can you bench i don't count 400 500
pounds
whatever is that for real whatever
benching is when you're on your back and
you lift it right
is that benching yes so you know what
that was what you just said
but
good bring on this this is gonna be good
okay
what is emily blunt doing right now
unfortunately talking to dwayne johnson
that's what i'm doing
a dream come true dream come true like
what are you doing right now
like a movie or like actually i think
they actually i think
in the moment you have fans that are
just so fanatical
they want to know what you're doing what
was emily blunt's
first movie my first movie was a movie
called my summer of love
it's quite a racy movie it was a little
independent movie that pavel pablokovsky
directed
who taught me pretty much everything wow
because i didn't
train and i feel like i learned so much
from him about
how old were you uh 20 20 your first
movie what was it called the summer
my summer of love and it's about this
romance between
two 16 year old girls over the course of
this long hot summer they come from
different
walks of life different backgrounds and
they have this sort of mad summer
and i played a very manipulative nasty
girl
well that was a reality for me was it
yeah
keep going rip it just rip it what you
got
what is emily blunt oh for god's sake
herpes medicine no
no accent oh who knows
british british but from what part
it's like a south west london but for me
and for a lot of people
what is what is this straight just
straight english accent straight english
not too posh not too cockney got it
something rather in the middle
in the middle but quite posh probably a
little question okay
what does emily blunt you keep going the
wrong way here what does emily blunt
think of the office i love the office
i have watched every episode and i see
why it's that show
that just keeps going and going do you
know 16 year olds are watching the
office now like 12 year olds are
watching the office now yeah
well it's so good the quality of it is
so good you've never seen an episode i
have
i have no no i have it's amazing and the
guy and he comes in and he's like dying
oh and he's like wow he's like hey
there's smokes yeah it's so good so good
does dwayne johnson have a stunt
do you play video games i do want to
know that i used to be a badass dude
that was the best call of duty what was
it i was just
all of them no i was yeah were you
pretty good the best good with your
thumbs
i'm great with my thumbs does dwayne
johnson do yoga
do you think he does yoga no the answer
is yes
unflexi what do you mean i'm extremely
flexible the tin man at this point
does dwayne johnson have a dog i do have
a dog his name is hobbs
he's real yeah he's a little frenchy
does dwayne johnson fish
oh come on nerdy come on no doubt no
doubt fish a fish i love station i raise
my own fish too i raise
we're gonna nerd out for a minute for
all the fishermen out there raise my
largemouth bass variety of sun fish
so it gets really boring for a lot of
people hybrid striped bass
uh create a wonderful ecosystem anyway
go ahead
sorry guys if anyone blanked out yeah
all right here we go okay
does emily play does emily blunt dance
not really not very well
no no paul hey okay not at all
does emily bland sing kind of like what
what it was
no i'm not going to sing no but like
what do you like what do you enjoy
singing
i would prefer to sing like
no we're not doing it i'm not doing it
you're not going to drag me in no i love
a bit of sam cook he knows that little
lotus reading okay
okay let's do the next one what are we
right here how many blow wear glasses
she does and she needs to wear them more
[Music]
keep going yeah somebody wants to speak
spanish i understand a lot of spanish
and i don't speak it
very well stop it's not happening
i do i i understand it
great how dwayne johnson
met his wife in boston you're like when
was it
come on in boston uh we met at a uh
at a at a kickoff party yeah yeah in
boston we met at a kickoff party
is she interested in you well the funny
story is we started talking and then she
uh said well listen it was great to meet
you i'm gonna go she was like it's been
great
but we're done here take care of
yourself yes good
hooked you hooked me shook me why dwayne
johnson
is called the rock i don't know why
because i'm quite soft
except why you called the rock the birth
story of the rock
is before i do what i do now many moons
ago i used to throw around 300 pound men
for a living and
get my ass kicked and then my original
wrestling name
was rocky my via which was a combination
of my dad's first name and my
grandfather's last name because both of
them were pro wrestlers
so my name became rocky my via and when
it was first pitched to me from vince
mcmahon he said i i got your name and i
want it to be
rocky my via what do you think and as
and as
we he knows me now and that's how it's
because i hate it i
hate it and i hated the name i hated it
i hated it
why did you hate it the lineage i had
gave me the opportunity
yeah to at least knock on the door you
wanted your own space i wanted my own
identity
in my own space so i was very proud to
come from who i came from with my dad
and my grandfather my whole family is
in wrestling uh i still wanted my own
space and so i said i hate it and he
said okay
great well that's your name wow okay so
i embraced it and i did it
and um that name did not stick and
eventually
when i became a bad guy it got truncated
down to
the rock and uh a guy who was my father
figure and i've talked to you many times
about him pat patterson
um was a mentor of mine in pro wrestling
i lost him last year when i lost my dad
at the same time i lost my father and my
father figure in the
same year he said what if we call you
the rock he's a french guy a
tough french accent i said i love it he
goes okay you're the rock
love it come on come on come on can
dwayne johnson sing
no he cannot what is the deal
with the rocks flabby tummy what is the
deal with the rocks out what's wrong
with it what's wrong with the wrong side
who wrote that what is wrong with them
there's nothing wrong with him
no here's the thing oh god i think
because
on instagram all these instagram fitness
models have these incredible
6 8 12 24 pack stomachs
no i got like a five and a half pack
okay sometimes a four and a half pack
okay problem was which a lot of people
don't know i tore
in a wrestling match i tore my the top
of my quad off my pelvis
he went bang in a wrestling match and
then what that did that caused a chain
reaction
and it tore my abdomen wall so then i
had three i had to do
a triple hernia emergency surgery uh
of a tear a tear and a tear now they
look pretty
messed up yeah so they're not like
perfect
abs yes so you know what it's not his
fault guys
who are it's not not who are googling
what's wrong with the rock's abs okay
what's wrong
with your wrestling mattress where are
your abs and the top of my quad popped
off my pelvis
now and my adductor popped off my pelvis
and the pain
this is going to keep you up at night